vous l'avez vu l'alimentation biologique
est aujourd'hui présente dans certains
restaurants d'entreprise également ou
cantine d'établissements scolaires
reportage justement dans un collège à
evry en région parisienne laurence de
chef frédéric bon c'est quoi de
l'agriculture biologique
pourquoi c'est de la nourriture qui sort
de la terre c'est la nourriture
kepa chimiques et des produits naturels
ils en ont déjà entendu parler sans
vraiment comprendre une petite leçon ce
matin sur la nourriture biologique n'est
sûrement pas du luxe
à aucun moment de la production de la
culture de ces produits biologiques on
ne va introduire des produits des
substances artificielles ou chez i car
ce midi au collège des pyramides à evry
on mange bio à la cantine et c'est la
première fois
crudités sauté de dinde à compagnie de
riz fruits et yaourts les 160
adolescents inscrits à la cantine un
test un repas complet et là les avis
sont partagés
c'est plus crémeuse crois qu'un
différent c'est une chose
certains sont loin de réclamer du rab
mais ont compris l'intérêt de ces
nouveaux produits
elle s'allie pas trop l'environnement
respecte l'environnement avec les
produits bio
on fait pas pourquoi parce que sinon
assez bas y'a rien qui a ajouté brad we
norman s'aimer pour leur santé pourquoi
ça correspondait des vitamines
un repas qui coûte 30% plus cher
impossible donc de mettre en place ces
menus chaque semaine organiser ce type
de repas nécessite une logistique plus
compliqué il est bien évident que la
logistique prépondérant que je dirais
dans le cou de menu car faire traverser
la france à cinq kilos de riz c'est pas
la même chose et on arrive à un surcoût
au kilo très très important
école entreprise hôpitaux sur mille
repas servis en collectivité l'année
dernière un seul et c'est bio